Welcome to the explainer. So today we're
taking a virtual tour of the absolute
central hub of Jewish life. This is for
your AQA religious studies GCSE revision,
and we're looking at the synagogue and
public worship.
My goal today? To give you a highly
focused breakdown of exactly what you need
to know for your exam. So grab a drink,
get comfortable, and let's start our tour.
Looking at our unit map for Judaism
practices, you'll see it's broken down
into four key steps. Today is step one,
which means we're focusing entirely on the
building itself and the public worship
that happens inside it.
Once we've got that mastered, our future
explainers are going to cover home worship
on Shabbat, major life events, and finally
dietary laws and festivals.
But today, it's all about the community
hub.
Here's our agenda for today. First,
context and community, so the outside.
Second, sacred architecture, the inside.
Third, two traditions, and finally, the
heartbeat of worship.
Section one, context and community, the
outside.
Okay, so before we actually step inside
the building, we have to ask, why is it
here at all? Like, why is it so absolutely
crucial?
To answer that, we've got to travel back a
couple of millennia to the year 70 CE.
And guys, this is a really important
historical anchor for your exam.
In 70 CE, the Second Temple in Jerusalem
was destroyed.
Now, before that exact moment, the temple
was literally the singular center of
Jewish worship. But with its destruction,
the synagogue had to become the new focus
of Jewish religious life. And now they're
everywhere there's a Jewish community.
Just to ground this in our own history,
the oldest synagogue in continuous use in
the UK is the Bevis Marks Synagogue in
London, and that was built all the way
back in 1701. Crazy, right? Now, I've got
a brilliant little exam sheet code for you
here, the rule of three. The synagogue
actually serves three distinct functions,
and each has a specific Hebrew term.
First, we have Bet Knesset, which
translates to house of assembly, and this
is where the community gathers for events
and socializing. Second is Bet Tefillah,
the house of prayer, which is the space
used for public worship services. And
third is Bet Midrash, the house of study,
where adults and children go for Torah
learning and education.
If you can memorize these three terms and
their exact functions, you are going to
have a rock solid foundation for
absolutely any question about the
synagogue's purpose. Section two, sacred
architecture, the inside.
All right, stepping through the front
doors, there are three absolutely crucial
physical features of this space that you
need to know.
First up is the bimah. This is the raised
reading platform where the Torah scroll is
placed to be read publicly to the
congregation.
But here's the key distinction you really
need for your exam.
Its location actually changes depending on
the tradition.
So, in traditional Orthodox synagogues,
the bimah sits right in the center of the
hall. This reflects the ancient temple's
design, and it lets the congregation
literally surround the reader. But in most
Reform synagogues, the bimah is positioned
right at the front, which really
emphasizes the unity of the service and
the leadership role of the rabbi. Now,
what's really interesting about this next
feature is just how incredibly revered it
is, the Aaron HaKodesh, or the Holy Ark.
You can kind of think of it like a
beautifully ornate VIP vault.
It is the most sacred object in the entire
synagogue because it houses the Torah
scrolls, which are often dressed in these
absolutely gorgeous embroidered covers and
silver ornaments. Opening the ark is a
really solemn moment where the entire
congregation actually rises to their feet.
Also, and this is crucial, the ark is
always placed on the wall facing
Jerusalem, which, if you're taking your
exam in the UK, means it's usually on the
east wall.
And right above that ark is our third
feature, the Neer Temid, the eternal
light. You can sort of think of the Neer
Temid like an always on notification light
that literally never, ever turns off. It's
kept burning constantly to symbolize God's
eternal, unwavering presence.
Historically, this links right back to the
menorah, you know, the seven-branched lamp
that burned continuously in that ancient
temple we talked about earlier. And it
doesn't matter if a synagogue is Orthodox
or Reform, you are for sure going to find
the Nert Amid shining there.
Section three, two traditions, Orthodox
versus Reform.
So how do these two distinct congregations
actually conduct worship within the exact
same walls? Well, one of the most visible
differences is seating and also the role
of women. In an Orthodox synagogue, men
and women sit separately.
Very often, women will sit in an upper
gallery or behind a partitioned area.
And there's a very specific term for this
dividing screen that you should definitely
write down, the mechitza. Plus, in
Orthodox practice, only men lead the
services and read from the Torah. In
Reform synagogues, however, the approach
is quite different. The seating is fully
mixed, so men and women sit together.
Women can freely lead the services, and
women are actually regularly ordained as
rabbis. And this brilliantly illustrates
the difference in the whole sensory
experience of the services too. If you
attend an Orthodox service, you're going
to hear Hebrew used almost exclusively,
with prayers that literally haven't
changed for centuries. You also won't hear
any musical instruments on Shabbat,
because playing instruments isn't
permitted on the day of rest.
Instead, you'll hear this traditional,
unaccompanied cantorial singing.
In a Reform service, on the other hand,
the language is a mixture of Hebrew and
English. That makes the translations
readily accessible to everyone in the
room. And from a musical standpoint,
Reform communities frequently use organs
or other instruments to accompany their
singing, even on Shabbat.
But listen, I really don't want you to
walk away from this thinking these are two
entirely different religions. It is
absolutely vital to remember that despite
these stylistic differences in seating,
language, and music, both traditions share
the exact same fundamental bedrock
beliefs.
Whether they're Orthodox or Reformed, they
both fiercely affirm God's oneness, the
covenant, and the mitzvot. And physically,
when they stand to pray, both
congregations face the exact same
direction, Jerusalem.
Section 4, the action, the heartbeat of
worship.
So what exactly are they praying when they
face Jerusalem?
Well, at the heart of every single Jewish
service is the Amidah.
Literally translated, it means the
standing one, and it is the most important
regular prayer in Jewish worship. During
the Amidah, worshippers stand completely
focused, with their feet pressed tightly
together, facing Jerusalem.
And they don't just do this once a week,
they do this three times every single day,
morning, afternoon, and evening. And hey,
look at this, it's our rule of three cheat
code for the third time today. It's almost
like they planned it.
The Amidah itself is chronologically
broken down into three distinct phases.
Phase one opens with three blessings of
praise to God.
Phase two makes up the core of the weekday
prayer, consisting of 13 petitions,
basically asking God for things like
understanding, healing, and forgiveness.
Finally, phase three closes the prayer
with three blessings of thanksgiving.
Now, a really quick note for your exam. On
Shabbat, the day of rest, those 13 middle
petitions are actually removed. They're
swapped out for a single blessing about
the holiness of the day. This
intentionally shortens the service, making
sure worshippers can focus on rest rather
than asking for everyday needs.
Now, we've mentioned several times today
that the Aaron HaKodesh faces Jerusalem
and that the Amidah is prayed facing
Jerusalem.
But why? Well, let's look at this quote
from 1 Kings.
This is from King Solomon's prayer at the
dedication of the very first temple.
He asked God to hear the plea of your
servant and of your people Israel when
they pray toward this place. So even after
the temple was destroyed centuries later,
this physical orientation remained. It
expresses this eternal longing and a
continued unbreakable connection to the
spiritual center of Jewish life.
It quite literally unites Jews all over
the world.
Wherever they are on the globe, they are
all facing the exact same spot.
Which brings us to a final thought for you
to take away today.
The architecture of the synagogue and the
structure of the daily prayers are all
purposefully designed to orient a person's
physical and spiritual attention towards
one unifying location. It kind of makes
you think, if you had to physically orient
your entire life, all your focus, and all
your hopes toward one single place in the
world, what would it be? Hm. Think about
that as you review your notes today.
Thanks for joining me on The Explainer,
and I will see you for step two of our
revision series very soon.